any advice when you want to change  careers change them that's my [ __ ]  advice everybody overthinks everything  everybody Ponders everything like the  best strategies to [ __ ] do like  everybody [ __ ] debating cynicism  everybody cares about all the details  like who gives a [ __ ] that's it like you  don't need me on [ __ ] Instagram live  telling you to do it you don't need your  mom to do it just [ __ ] do it like if  you're so [ __ ] miserable you want to  check and change careers change careers  like if I [ __ ] thought through  everything I've done in my life I  wouldn't have done anything none of it  made sense hey let's document everything  and then create micro content let's  [ __ ] invest in these [ __ ]  companies that nobody's ever [ __ ]  heard of let's [ __ ] sell wine on the  internet like [ __ ] do [ __ ]